okay this time let's do an easy one okay
so now we're playing - seven I'm
expecting that to be pretty easy as as
is well known even my mother can beat -
at age seven okay let's try and just
play solid chess and see what it does so
this is the name so Indian we're
fighting for the central squares e d4 d5
and so far - is playing normal moves
however this one while not being bad
it's not the most common moving in this
line because it doesn't address the two
central squares efore and d5 that we're
fighting over here so but once again
explain more or less normal developing
moves so there's nothing in particular
to complain about little minuses play
just developing my pieces now he plays
this move instantly and I have no idea
what his idea is
okay let's try and trick him now the
bishop is sort of threatening the Queen
through an x-ray so yeah he was just
intending to lose a temple that's fine
by me
I'm just continuing to develop my pieces
and now it's becoming more and more
clear that Magnus 7 is not quite at a
very high level yet but I still need to
exploit his mistakes
so now it seems that my pieces are are
well developed they're all pointing
towards the center and so I need to
strike and now I took the pawn he moved
the king leaving his knight uncovered on
c3 so I'm just going to take that one
now it's just now it's just making
random moves
unfortunately so let's bring my Knights
into the attack
so it's threatening my bishop I
naturally make a very brave retreat one
thing that it's admirable is the the
speed and the confidence
- sevens play because he's making some
well surprising moves right now but it's
doing it with with great confidence so
now I'm a piece up with active pieces on
this little move I'm threatening a check
which Magnus 7 missed let's pause for a
second and see if you can see it as well
I've actually I have two ways to win his
Queen right now so check he has to take
it and now this uncovered an attack on
the Queen by the bishop so he should
have taken back the bishop when we would
have traded two minor pieces for a queen
which is a bad trade for -7 obviously
but you could have placed quite a few
more moves but now I'm taking his rook
as well and it's his armies pretty
depleted right now now now it's really a
matter of just
mark mopping up taking whatever pieces I
please so now he's threatening to rooks
at once but I have this little light
fork for King his rook and Bishop which
ensure that I'm not actually losing an
impending material he fights on bravely
but now yeah now I just need to find a
way to check my turn so I'm bringing my
last work into play what's the quickest
way to meet here I'm just going to play
give up my rook well he didn't want to
take my work and now let's pause for a
minute see if I can checkmate in one
move and yes I can
his king is caught and I won the game
and a few points as well that's nice
okay